bonsoir On a vu récemment que vous étiez
réconcilié avec Arthur et on voit
partout depuis deux jours qui vous
demande 9 millions on en est où avec ça
c'est une vieille affaire c'est une
vieille à faire il y a aucun problème
aucun problème ouais ouais bonsoir
Benaim magazine je voulais savoir si
une boulette
et société
différentes sorties sur le service
public est-ce que la direction de Canal+
vous a demandé de lever le pied pas du
tout la néocané direction Canal+ ne me
demande jamais de lever le pied
sachez-le la direction de Canal+ on a la
plus grande liberté ici voilà je vous le
dis et et j'ai aucun problème avec mes
dernières sorties et s'il faut le redire
je le redirai voilà donc je vais vous
dire je m'en fous alors j'ai vu tous les
tous les voilà tous les bobos qui sont
soulevés j'ai vu un sketch sur France 5
mais d'une nullité d'un mec qui
s'appelle Picon je pense il parle bien
son nom
vous savez le mec là je sais plus je
sais même pas comment il s'appelle un
boulot voilà non mais c'est un gugusse
je sais pas quoi là
guignol qui a fait un sketch nulissim je
sais pas chez voilà bon voilà donc voilà
vous recevez bon nombre d'hommes
politiques vers lequel allez-vous vous
rapprocher au niveau des idées
il va pas répondre frère il y a pas
d'élection hein non il y a pas
d'élection mais vous avez reçu tout un
tas d'hommes politiques de tout bord
d'ailleurs ce qui est votre force aussi
vers lequel vous sentez vous alors je
vais dire la vérité j'étais et je l'ai
jamais caché ici c'est vrai que je
m'entendais très bien avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
[Rires]
je m'entends très bien avec mais en fait
je m'entends bien avec tout le monde
vous avez bien choisi la vérité je monte
très bien avec Fabien je m'entends très
bien avec les équipes de Jordan Bardella
je dis la vérité voilà je m'entends très
bien avec Sandrine Rousseau mine de rien
une mission on a rigolé on s'entend bien
voilà en fait tu m'entends je m'entends
plutôt bien avec tout le monde sauf avec
Mathilde panot et Louis Boyard voilà
sinon éventuellement alors Anne Hidalgo
vous entendez pas exactement
les travaux ça peut s'arranger avec un
Hidalgo je pense aussi vous devriez
faire un pas pourquoi vous le faites pas
[Rires]
parce qu'à un moment vous vouliez ouvrir
un peu à des personnalités très connues
est-ce qu'il y a une personnalité que
vous voulez recevoir non j'aimerais bien
faire une spéciale ou avec ou avec avec
Zidane voilà oui
tout ça avec Didier ouais ça serait ça
serait bien alors vous êtes complètement
vous êtes à fond dans cette histoire
est-ce que
au tour de la table
vous aimeriez vous séparer d'une
personne qui est parmi nous ce soir
elle est de ce côté
elle coûte cher
non c'est pas vous
on a vu récemment que vous avez testé
beaucoup d'autres chroniqueurs vraiment
beaucoup ça a beaucoup tourné depuis
deux semaines et là on voit qu'on
retourne un peu on retrouve un peu la
base
parce que les autres ne sont pas libres
ne vous enflammez pas voilà tout
simplement là oui
dévisse magazine
quel est votre créez votre sentiment sur
les cochons bancaires
je voulais juste savoir
si vous deviez présenter un énorme prime
avec un COP présenté avec quelle
présentateur chaîne toutes chaînes
confondue qu'elle présente
je vous le dis ça c'est clair voilà et
deux numéros
de porter une personne justement à la
gloire au sommet à part mon fils
et ça vous dirait pas de reprendre une
vieille gloire de la télévision et de
lui le redonner une autre nouvelle
condition
[Rires]
avec Sabatier avec Patrick Sébastien
avec la gaffe
Julien Courbet
qui sont toujours des gloires
pour moi je vous dis je déteste mon mecs
qui disent on est Habib on est pour moi
il y a pas de has been un mec voilà
c'est c'est voilà c'est c'est moi ils
ont eu des succès énorme tous les mecs
comme vous comme Benjamin comme Valérie
comme Bernard
voilà
non mais oui est-ce que vous avez dans
votre carrière parfois doutez eu peur
que ça s'arrête avant que ce soit la
folie
il peut avoir peur encore
moi je doute pas mais on peut avoir peur
bien sûr bien sûr voilà et moi je vais
vous dire moi c'est mon kif d'être ici
je vous jure que c'est vrai je le dis
mais quand le weekend je pense à une
connerie je pense à une chose c'est la
partager avec vous vous recevrez quand
je vais le dire aux gens qui sont morts
dans le public aux gens qui me regardent
à la télé quand je vais dire cette
connerie je suis comme un fou je pense
qu'à une chose comme un gamin pour vous
dire la connerie voilà pour vous
retrouver pour vous raconter des trucs
là j'étais comme un fou là j'ai reçu le
mail là de mon assistant qui m'a dit
complément donné j'avais qu'une envie
c'était de vous le dire ouais ou pas en
fait c'est ça en fait tu regardes en
fait il y avait qu'une envie c'était de
le dire au téléspectateur voilà c'est
voilà donc en fait non c'est pas non
avoir un moment un moment je dis la
vérité à un moment j'ai failli arrêter
moi bah oui attends un moment quand tu
manges tous les jours des chips et du
[Rires]
voilà la Playstation voilà c'est tout
donc non non je vous dis non non pas les
cours il travaille à l'école ils vont
pas que ça non non mais en plus
je suis pas là la presse vraiment non
mais ça me touche pas du tout et en plus
je ne lis jamais c'est-à-dire que je je
n'ai pas de contact avec eux oui est-ce
que dans un coin de votre tête on se
crée vous savez quand est-ce que vous
allez arrêter bien sûr et personne n'est
sérieux bien sûr ah bah oui vous avez
déjà ça rejoint ma question est-ce que
vous pensez à une carrière longue à la
Drucker ou est-ce que vous pensez plutôt
devenir un jour patron d'une chaîne ou
en tout cas des programmes moi je vois
bien patron de Luxembourg
[Rires]
j'étais très bien mais voilà ça me dit
rien du tout moi j'ai qu'une envie moi
je vous dis c'est dire des conneries ou
téléspectateurs donc je continuerai à
dire des conneries voilà combien de
temps en tout cas vous savez et personne
le sait où les gens même pas vos parents
rien merci
quand je vais manger une boulette
[Rires]
oui moi j'ai une question vraiment à
bout les routiers en chaleur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un magazine qui tire à 50000
exemplaires c'est très important ce
complément d'enquête est-ce que vous
êtes ravi
oui
est-ce que vous êtes ravis qu'avec
l'argent du contribuable il fasse une
émission pour vous alors qu'il y a
peut-être d'autres complément d'enquête
plus importante à faire ou est-ce que
vous en foutez vous êtes ravis je m'en
fous totalement donc en fait ils vont
dépenser de l'argent pour rien mais non
mais c'est pas mal
vous en foutez en fait complètement une
question pour complément d'en quéquette
quelle
c'est que vous n'avez pas de zizi mais
quelle femme connue vous ferez retrouver
votre zizi il y a aucune femme qui me
vient à l'esprit je vous jure que c'est
vrai
je vous jure que c'est vrai j'en parlais
un peu avec un pote et voilà
les plus belles femmes
du monde sont ici
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
vraiment très très bons moments avec
Géraldine aussi tous vraiment vous vous
étiez très heureux à la radio vous êtes
beaucoup amusé ce que éventuellement
pourriez retourner en radio
je sais pas pour l'instant on va voir
c'est pas pas l'ordre du jour on a
beaucoup de paddle très sympa la radio
c'est très agréable
si c'est pour aller faire un safari je
suis déjà
j'avais sans doute plein de projets donc
sans doute confidentiel en télé mais
est-ce que pour les téléspectateurs ce
soir vous pourriez nous donner un nom
d'émission ou un thème d'émission que
vous auriez envie de lancer que vous ou
que vous allez lancer bientôt sur scène
et ce sera une émission voilà appelle à
témoin ça va s'appeler fais tout à Fatou
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on est dans TPMP
quand il est mission j'ai une idée allez
on y a un mois après la lentaine frère
tu vois bien il y a eu des chaussures
il y a eu des bails ou même moi je
savais même pas ce que c'était
l'émission j'avais que le titre et la
chaîne en fait ce qui se passe c'est qui
vous appelle trois semaines avant vous
voyez on doit donner parce qu'il y a
tous les jours de télé tout ça tu dois
donner ce que tu vas mettre à l'antenne
trois semaines avant et genre il m'a
appelé
je vous dise la vérité mais même face à
Baba face à Baba à la base je me
rappelle c'était un
je devais faire un prime m'avait dit
ouais tu feras un prime je sais plus
c'était en novembre je sais pas quoi et
ils me disent bon le mardi il m'appelle
pour trois semaines après le mardi matin
9h je devais faire un grand jeu genre
qui voilà un truc avec des conneries des
apnings tout ça et là j'ai mes équipes à
10h j'ai Lionel stade le directeur
général l'émission il me dit alors on
fait le jeu là tout ça et tout je dis
non il y a que on doit donner il me dit
11h je dis attends 2 minutes et je vous
dis la vérité on était en période
présidentielle et je dis bah tu sais
quoi je dis qu'est-ce qui cartonne en ce
moment-là il me dit bah je sais pas
regarde dans les sondages tout ça bah
j'ai dit bah tu sais quoi tu m'appelles
tout le monde tu m'appelles Emmanuel tu
m'appelles le président Emmanuel Macron
tu m'appelles Eric Zemmour tu m'appelles
tu m'appelles
Marine Le Pen et tu m'appelles je
t'avais dit Valérie Pécresse elle était
encore là c'est ici j'ai dit le premier
qui dit oui tu dis qu'il va faire une
émission avec moi pour les
présidentielles premier qui a dit oui
c'est Éric Zemmour
donc là on n'a pas le nom de l'émission
et là la chaîne m'appelle à 11h il me
disent alors on met quoi dans trois
semaines je dis bah tu mets une émission
et qui est Hanouna Éric Zemmour elle me
dit mais comment s'appelle je sais pas
ça va
Éric Zemmour et on en fera comme ça avec
tous les candidats de la présidentielle
ah ouais bah ouais voilà mon frère ça et
donc c'est parti comme ça mais on avait
pas du tout prévu de faire face à
l'avoir au départ c'était une émission
de divertissement qu'on devait faire ce
jour-là et on a mis face à Baba voilà
donc pour vous dire la chaîne on a une
liberté c'est voilà ils nous font il
nous faut confiance et après c'est vrai
voilà ça ça a bien marché après on a
appelé après on a eu Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui a dit ok voilà et en fait il on a on
a enchaîné avec les autres d'autres
questions on connaît votre fidélité au
groupe Canal+ mais imaginons vraiment
que pour une raison vous ne pouvez plus
être dans le groupe Canal+ quelle chaîne
vous choisiriez ça peut même être une
petite chaîne c'est quelle chaîne vous
choisirez franchement maintenant la
vérité je pense franchement que alors
j'adore je m'entends très bien avec M6
tout ça mais aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je
pense franchement que la télé comme on
l'a fait nous aujourd'hui c'est
impossible pour moi je ferai un nouveau
truc j'irai sur une plateforme je fais
un truc en direct sur une plateforme
c'est-à-dire vraiment un truc voilà
nouveau c'est un taux sur une plateforme
avec tout le monde voilà on refait des
darkades des trucs voilà ça on a plus de
on a plus de gars qui viennent nous dire
il faut pas dire s'il faut pas dire ça
voilà donc franchement moi je ferai ça
voilà il y a parce que my canal Carson
on sait jamais voilà c'est c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui voilà nous on a la chance
et je vous jure et je le dis merci
encore au téléspectateurs tous les soirs
parce que c'est incroyable les scores de
dans ce qu'on fait parce que je pense
qu'on est en direct et les gens disent
ici ils peuvent toujours se passer
quelque chose et c'est vrai que ils vont
moins sur les plateformes à cette
heure-ci parce que ils se disent c'est
vrai que TPMP on s'est voilà tu as envie
de le voir en direct c'est vrai tu as
envie de le voir tu as envie de voir ce
qui s'est passé en direct mais
aujourd'hui la télé traditionnelle on le
voit c'est très compliqué et c'est vrai
que les gens moi même moi
la télé traditionnelle je regarde que
les voilà que les les les les les
les grands événements sportifs et deux
trois trucs mais je regarde pas du tout
je voilà et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je
pense que nous on a une chance
incroyable d'avoir un public aussi
fidèle et qui soit tous les soirs là
parce que je voilà c'est on le voit
toutes les émissions des clients j'ai eu
un article à la rue qu'on est les seuls
à progresser voilà sur un an c'est un
truc de fou donc merci encore à vous
merci les chéris d'autres questions
merci voilà